hi i'm daisy lowe and this is my
glamifesto
for life
[Music]
my daily mantra is try my best to live
in the present because
that's all we have my instant mood
booster is dancing
dancing to absolutely anything but 90s r
b
seems to get me the most amped
i think it's really important to fail
i'm
not great at allowing myself to fail
i've been
a huge fan of elizabeth day's podcast
how to fail because it makes me feel
better about failing every single day
the best remedy for failure is just try
again
something that makes me feel really
passionate is taking care of the
environment
the best of my ability vintage shopping
is
so important to me because you can find
one-of-a-kind gems
it's been so eye-opening recently
learning these incredible incredibly
terrifying statistics
and through working with this brilliant
company called where a third of clothing
the carbon footprint from the fashion
industry is actually
coming from how we care for our clothes
my boyfriend's gonna be so mad at me the
one thing
that i couldn't live without is actually
my dog monty who
is the ultimate little wizard
trapped in a dog's body and the best
sidekick a girl could wish for
glamour means so much to me
self-expression self-care to feel
elevated to take care of yourself
and glam of the magazine has been a huge
part of my life since i was
a teenager it was the first kind of
adult magazine that i ever bought myself
i think i feel most glam when i
am going out with the girls because
before going out with the girls
you know that there is a lot of care and
time
and nurture that goes into making me
feel like my best self to be with my
favorite ladies
what i value most in friendship is just
that
beautiful trust loyalty symbiosis
humor understanding lack of judgment
the best thing that i've learned from
this past difficult year
there's been so much patience
you know learning to actually take some
time and space and
just stop and breathe i think my biggest
achievement is that i'm
still here with a smile on my face god
that's a really difficult one for
someone that's also really
self-deprecating
i manage my mental health with so many
tools
meditation is something that helps me a
lot exercise is a huge
part of my kind of self-care for my
mental health
i'm terrible at running but i do still
try i'd say the quirkiest thing that i
do
in terms of wellness there's a few okay
so
every summer solstice spring equinox
winter solstice and autumn equinox i
always do list burning rituals so i
write one list where i write down
everything that i release
and then i write a list of everything
that i want to welcome into my life
i try every full moon to put all of my
crystals outside
um into the moonlight to charge the one
book that changed my life
um it would have to be there's a
brilliant book called anita
morgani called dying to be me it's all
about kind of following your own bliss
over the years um my mum has given me
always the most incredible advice she
she's actually
the person who has always tried to teach
me to be really present
and that you know the past doesn't exist
neither does the future you just have to
make the most of what we have right now
i would like my legacy to be i was
someone who
made people feel bright and
confident in themselves that i was kind
and i made a positive impact on the
world
you